hello everybody markiplier here and
thank you guys so much for being with me
through a thousand videos it's it's hard
to even imagine how we've gotten from
this point and I really wanted to do
something special for the thousand
subscriber milestone or not thousand
subscriber thousand video milestone and
uh I think this video is really gonna
explain to you guys how I got from point
A to point B and how you guys have
helped change my life because um these
things are really important to me
because they tell how I became the
person that I am and I really do
appreciate you guys for sticking with me
so here we go
I was born on an island in the middle of
the Pacific Ocean called Oahu which is
the third largest island of Hawaii and
home to the city of Honolulu where I was
born on a military base my dad was a
career army man he had been in the army
23 years before he retired and
apparently while he was stationed in
Korea he met my mom a pretty common
story I've heard but the result of them
meaning was me a beautiful baby that was
not really beautiful there but my
artistic skills are lacking anyway
regardless of all of that I was born and
I was born awesome and muscular I was a
gigantic baby apparently which my mom
reminds me of every once in a while I
was ten pounds and three ounces and
therefore they named me mark all muscle
of course don't doubt me shortly after I
was born my dad retired from the
military to pick up a job as a layout
artist for a book company of some sort
but either way we ended up in Cincinnati
Ohio of all places not really sure why
because I don't think we really have any
family here at either way we moved into
this awesome home with a gigantic
backyard that led into these really
amazing woods where me and my brothers
spend most of our time I mean if we
weren't on the computer we were out in
the woods playing in the creek picking
up tadpoles cutting vines swinging on
them I mean we really bonded together
over those woods and that's one of the
things that I miss most about that house
but when we weren't in the woods we were
playing on this magical device called
the computer that my dad introduced us
to at a very early age I mean seriously
this thing bloom
my mind at the time because I could not
imagine ever living without it I mean he
told me stories about how computers were
ancient and filled up entire rooms but I
was just flabbergasted that I could do
what it did I didn't even know about the
internet back then there were a few
games on the computer but the real
experience that I got from gaming came
from the Super Nintendo system that my
brother got for Christmas I mean this
thing was the reason that me and my
brother is so close today because we
played so many games together with it
that's my brother over on the left his
name is Tom and that's me on the right
as you can tell I am still more awesome
but he's a pretty cool guy and I don't
think I'd be who I am today without him
sadly it wasn't all happy times back
then my dad and my mom fought a lot and
bi fought a lot I mean my mom fought a
lot and my dad had to reciprocate she
wasn't happy where she was and well we
didn't understand why but me and my
brother just tried to distract ourselves
with video games you know try to ignore
it what we can but eventually that
stopped working
it was pretty inevitable but the divorce
finally came and we were pretty sad but
we were more sad to see our dad just
kind of cave in I mean we were out of
money half the income was gone so we had
to lose the house we didn't couldn't buy
as many games as we had before so we
lost out on a lot of gaming but at least
we got to keep the computer and that's
what really sparked my love of computers
and technology I should also mention
that I was a pretty dumb kid me and my
brother had a contest where we would try
to jump as high as we could off the
stairs and see who could land on a
cushion at the bottom I was gonna win
but I ended up cracking my skull open on
the bottom step this will make more
sense later but as I mentioned before I
was a dumb kid when we moved out of the
house I could no longer go to the
private school that we were going to
which was perfectly fine with me because
I didn't really care but it's all that I
knew I didn't even understand what
lockers were all about when I went to
the new school I mean just everything
was perfectly foreign to me and I I
didn't have an escape I didn't go to the
woods anymore and I lost pretty much all
of my friends and had to start all over
it was a pretty dark time for me because
I had no idea what I was doing
but anyway I made some friends but I
accidentally did something else stupid
and I was having a how far out the
monkey bars can you jump contest and I
was gonna win but I ended up falling on
the ground and breaking my arm like
really badly old bones and stuff they're
popping out everywhere but this is
actually a good thing as my brother
they're shocked but this is a good thing
because this led to me finding some
friends and you may ask well how did
that happen well it weapon like this I
had a cast on my arm and couldn't do
things like sharpen my pencil so this
really awesome guy named drew decided
that he was gonna help me and drew is a
tall redhead but he was a cool guy
anyway he also got me more into band
which is where I made a bunch more
friends and where I blew his face off
with my awesome trumpeting skills but
all eventually after dating around for a
long time my dad found someone that we
could all agree on she was pretty much
the nicest person that we ever met and
her name was Dee I mean I agreed with
her because she bought us a Playstation
2 and I was pretty excited at a time but
also she did something that we couldn't
do at that time and she made my dad
happy and that was pretty much the most
important thing that anyone could do and
from then on high school started to
become a breeze I was moving through the
grades you know doing fine being a good
student I made a lot of great friends
both in band and out of band I got to
play some great games you know I was
really happy with what I done like
half-life 2 and stuff and I had a few
girlfriends here and there you know and
that's always pretty fun when you're
just a young teenager and first
experiencing the wonders of a
relationship and making out and stuff
that was pretty cool and all in all
things were looking up from that period
where we didn't really have anything and
didn't have games again and we're kind
of unhappy drifting through life so
things were looking up all the weights
going to college and I was really
excited to be finally be able to go out
on my own
but then my father bought brought me
some bad news
he put a piece of paper in front of me
and just let me read it without saying
anything and I was pretty smart kid so I
understood every word that it said all
the techno mumbo-jumbo but the main
thing is that in basically big bold
letters it said cancer and the really
bad kind of cancer so that was a really
tough time for me because I I kind of
lost sight of what I was doing
everything seemed kinda clear to me
before but right now everything was kind
of just getting away from me I thought I
knew exactly what I wanted to do which
was make video games I wanted to do it
my dad didn't agree with me but I
thought that that was what I was gonna
do however I started to realize that
games might not work so I kind of put
that off the table and focused on going
to engineering I was originally in civil
engineering but moved into biomedical
engineering because they had a medical
school program but that didn't work out
either I didn't want to do that so I
flip-flopped back to engineering again
and then I thought hey if I'm gonna do
what I want to do I gotta do games and I
really couldn't decide what I was gonna
do with my life I was kind of at a
crossroads and just frustrated then one
year later we were all home for summer
and my dad was getting pretty bad with
cancer and he wasn't himself anymore but
one morning we were all woken up by my
stepmom Dee screaming and we went
downstairs to see that my dad was dying
and the last words that he said to me
were I love you so much and I held my
dad's hand as he died
after my dad died I became more confused
than I was before because I was so far
into engineering that I didn't think
that I could get out anymore and I was
stuck in these mind-numbing co-op jobs
that were literally me sitting at a
computer eight hours a day doing two
hours worth of work and nothing else it
was absolutely horrible and I didn't
want to do that for the rest of my life
and I didn't have time for games I
didn't have an escape I had no idea what
I was gonna do so I kind of drifted for
a few years and I dated in and out from
girl to girl but I eventually met this
one girl who I kind of liked she was
really cool and really nice and her name
will be Barbara that's what we're
calling caller for now her name will be
Barbara with a c' but anyway i finally
brought her to my mom who i was living
with because after my dad died I didn't
have my own place and she did not
approve which made me an mad and she was
kind of confused I was very upset
because my mom got so mad that she
eventually kicked me out and this
there's more to it than that but that's
basically the long and the short of it
so I got mad and she got mad and then I
went off and get my own apartment
because I had a job at the time that
crummy co-op job but it was still a job
unfortunately after I got my new place
my boss told me three days before I was
closed to come in for the new quarter
that I didn't need to show up which made
me more mad but I didn't yell at my boss
professionalism and all that but at the
end of the day I was running out of
money and my girlfriend wasn't helping
me and then she started getting mad at
me for not being able to do something or
other I can't really remember why she
was mad she was mad so often but
eventually this caused a schism in the
relationship and the stress started to
get to me
I was sadder and sadder than I was
before and I just couldn't be in the
relationship anymore but after we left
each other
I was stuck alone in my apartment
and I didn't know what to do and I had
this suspicious pain in my side that
turned into extraordinary pain in my
side and this extraordinary pain plagued
me for a bit until one day I woke up in
so much pain that I had to go to the
hospital so I went to the hospital where
they told me that my appendix was about
the size of a beach ball and needed to
come out immediately they also told me
that I had a tumor the size of a fist in
my adrenal gland and that needed to come
out too but at a later date so this was
pretty shocking news and on top of
everything that had happened already I
was pretty much stressed enough as it is
but I managed to truck through it
somehow thankfully for reconciling with
my mom and my stepmom was still there
for me the surgeries went well and I
ended up recovering in the hospital for
about two weeks and had a lot of time to
think about what I'd done and the more
thinking I did the more frustrated I
became just it seemed like everything in
my life was completely out of my control
and I had no choice in the matter so
finally I decided that enough was enough
and I was gonna do what I wanted but I
was still stuck in the hospital so I got
angrier every day ah so when I finally
did get out of the hospital I decided
that I was gonna do my own thing and
what I decided I was gonna do was gonna
be sketch comedy videos so I ended up
using my tax refund that I had to buy a
camera I ended up doing very little with
this camera immediately so I decided to
focus on a few more things before I got
started I got better with my grades and
engineering I decided to dedicate myself
to playing games that I wanted to play
and then eventually I decided that I was
gonna make my own identity on the
Internet and more specifically on
YouTube where I was able to start a
channel that finally made me happy I
didn't even care that I didn't have that
many subscribers in the beginning
because even the few people that did
watch me I was more than happy to do
everything it took to entertain them but
as I kept playing things started
exploding like the subscriber count went
crazy and now I have more subscribers
and I know what to do with and I'm just
happy that anyone watches my videos
and that's what really changed my life
and it's happened very recently like
before I was totally out of control of
everything and now I'm finally able to
do what I love so thank you guys
sincerely I owe everything in my life
right now to the support that you have
given me I was lost before I I had no
purpose before but now we're able to
change the world do good raise money for
charity do just everything we want to do
to help improve the world and I am so
grateful that you guys decided that I
was worthy enough to subscribe to so
Cynthia sincerely thank you guys so much
I owe you everything that I have now and
I wouldn't have it any other way you
guys are the best fans in the world so
thank you again so much and as always I
will see you in the next video